- There's no instructions with this, no?
- [Gavin] No, it just
says climb in balloon.
- I've got my leg in and
it just seems painful.
Gonna have to fill it full of water now.
How am I gonna fit in this?
- Pull it over yourself.
That looks like you're
stood in a flower pot.
You're like a weird genie.
Hello there, welcome to this
episode of The Slow Mo Guys.
I'm currently stood next to
one of the funniest things
I've ever seen.
Dan look at this.
He's in the balloon.
It's the six foot balloon.
- Ow.
- We put him in it.
- Oh man.
- And now we're gonna
fill it 'til it pops.
So Dan, what you gotta try
and do is get further in it.
I wonder if you can drown in there.
- Easily.
Ow.
Oh, I'm in, I'm in.
I'm in.
Goddamn.
It's nice and refreshing actually.
- [Gavin] You look like
damn Jabba the Hut.
- It's quite nice.
Jabba the Hut .
Whoa!
Oh, I've got an itch
at the top of my head.
Can't do anything about it.
Hang on.
- [Gavin] You're like a slug.
With knees.
- I've got an itch on
my head, I can't get it.
Can you get it please?
- [Gavin] You got an itch?
- Yeah.
- [Gavin] Whereabouts.
- On like both sides of my
head like the temple area.
Not a stick, no, no.
Up a bit, up, up.
Oh, I got loads of room in here now.
- [Gavin] Have you?
- Yeah, I can spread my legs, oh!
- [Gavin] What was that?
- I dunno.
I can spread my legs out.
- [Gavin] Try and put your head under.
- No!
Hang on.
It's nice in there.
- [Gavin] Is it?
- Yeah.
- [Gavin] It's like a human-sized womb.
- Oh, got my boxers on in there.
- [Gavin] You should take off your boxers
and when you come out it looks like.
- Good lord!
- [Gavin] Oh my God.
- Oh man!
- [Gavin] You flooded the creek.
- Oh god.
It's just stupid, it's already funny.
- All right, I'm gonna play it.
Well, that was absolutely phenomenal.
I think that should go down in history
as one of the greatest
things ever shown in 4K.
It was your face as you'd
been given birth by that.
- Yeah, literally I was born.
- It looked like you got born again.
- Yeah, it was quite refreshing actually,
I quite enjoyed it.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, nice bit of sunshine.
- I gotta say, ever since we did
the original giant balloon
video, I've always wondered
what it would look like
if someone was inside.
- I looked online and I was
just looking for balloons
and I saw climb in balloons
and I was just like
it is time.
- It is time.
- Well, hopefully if you
enjoyed the original,
you liked that one as well.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt if you want.
Dan's not wearin' his today.
- Oh I'm not wearing mine today.
- We are gonna be making a shirt
of just his chest hair though
so look forward to that.
- That should be a thing, actually.
- Yeah, cool, yeah.
- Why not?
- And thank you so much for watching.
We'll see you in the next video.